- Hi, folks, my name is Bryan Landes.
I am a global solutions architect.
First off, welcome.
I hope you're having a great day.
I hope every one of you
makes like $5 million
in the casinos.
If you don't gamble, I hope
you're having great food.
And if you're anything
like me and you hate Vegas,
we're almost outta here.
I wanna introduce myself again.
My name is Bryan.
I've actually been supporting Toyota
for about seven and a half years.
And we wanted to actually
talk a little bit
about some generative AI use
cases and agentic platforms,
especially specifically in the dealership.
I'm here with Stephen and Stephen.
This is a little bit different.
And, you know, there's
definitely a lot of other talks.
I think BMW and Rivian,
a couple of others.
But we kinda wanted to
go a little bit different
this time around.
And we're actually having
two Toyota entities
on stage at once, right?
So we have Toyota Motor North America
and then also Toyota
Connected North America.
They will introduce
themselves in a second.
But again, I just wanna
thank you for being here.
By the way,
we do know how hard it is
to get around re:Invent.
We really do appreciate your time.
If you ever see us in these
orange badges running around,
we're trying to give you the best of show.
We know how things get a little crazy.
So again, thank you for being here.
So yeah, this is basically the flow.
This is what we are gonna be doing.
So I'm gonna come up here.
I'm gonna be about 100 level.
I'm just gonna kind of quickly
level set for a second.
I'm gonna actually talk a little bit
about the story of AWS and Toyota.
That's something that we
don't normally talk about,
but, you know, just kind of
wanted to give you a sneak peek.
I'm gonna pass it off to Stephen Ellis.
He's actually gonna tell you about TMNA,
or Toyota Motor North America's
gen AI enterprise approach.
And then we're gonna nerd
down with Stephen Short.
It's gonna be great.
So yeah, just to kind of level
set for a couple seconds.
Basically just to kind
of again, level set.
We look at our generative AI stack,
basically what you see here, right?
If we start from the
infrastructure layer, right,
we have multiple GPUs, P4s,
P5s, whatever have you.
And you also have SageMaker
that's actually doing the
undifferentiated heavy lifting
to basically help build out
models, whatever it may have,
within your actual stack itself.
If we actually go a little
bit higher up, right,
we use Amazon Bedrock,
which is our way of actually
helping provide LLMs at scale
for our users.
And then if we go a little bit higher,
you know, we still have Nova
Act and also we have Strands,
which is actually our
open source framework
to help build out agents
and deploy them at scale.
Again, we have Kiro, Amazon Q,
but I think more
importantly about this slide
is Toyota's using all this
in various different forms
and fashions, right?
So we try to democratize our AI tooling,
and this is kind of how they approach it.
But again, this is from AWS.
This is how we kind of
look at this whole thing.
I think what's kind of important too
is that we all may,
definitely by now, right?
I think ChatGPT like
launched three years ago.
You know, generative AI chat assistance
were kind of the big thing.
But what we are truly seeing,
and I feel like you know, even
with Swami's keynote today,
is that we are seeing gen
AI actually being deployed
throughout the enterprises
in different specific lines of businesses,
and it's actually becoming much
more agentic all throughout.
And in fact, when Stephen
Short gets up here
in a little bit, he'll
talk to you a little bit
about how he's actually
been working with AgentCore
to be able to deploy these agents at scale
within Toyota Connected and
also Toyota Motor North America.
And that's kind of why we built AgentCore.
I don't know how many of you all may
or may not be using the AgentCore,
but basically this is our service
to have composable infrastructure units
so that you can basically
deploy agents at scale.
So instead of spending 20
months writing identity scripts
or trying to figure out observability
with Datadog for six hours,
you know, basically we have actually
built out these composable points
that you can use with your agents
and be able to deploy
them at scale, right?
'Cause a lot of time we were all trying
to kind of figure out like do
we keep making chat assistants
but actually how do we actually work
with these LLM and agents?
And so that's why this is actually made
and that's what we are
seeing used at scale.
Very quickly just kind of
show you a little bit more
about AgentCore.
I'm not sure if a lot
of folks may or may not
have used AgentCore.
I feel like it's still relatively,
you know, day one service.
But basically this is a
great small example, right,
where you have an application
that might be hitting API
calls to AgentCore runtime,
which is an isolated VM,
so that basically you can have
your own secure environment.
And then you can use any
type of framework, right?
It's actually a framework agnostic
and also LLM agnostic, right?
But in these particular examples,
it's Strands, LlamaIndex,
LangGraph, and also CrewAI, right?
And so basically you would
use these frameworks,
and then you would be able
to deploy these frameworks
and your agents with, again,
the actual AgentCore runtime.
Also there's AgentCore Gateway,
which Stephen Short will talk
about in a couple minutes
about how he's implemented with that.
And then also there's some actual tools
that come out of the box
such as AgentCore browser
and also your code interpreter.
I don't know if anyone's
actually working a lot
with agents as well.
Identity is kind of a very
hard challenge, right,
off Z and off N.
So we actually take this away from you
and help you with this
and so you can actually
have true identities
with your agents without going too crazy
or letting them go off
on their own, right?
Last but not least is memory.
That's a huge thing.
Context windows and everything, right?
Again, we take that away, and
we put it on our backbone.
And then also last but not least
is the observability layer.
You want to actually know
what these agents are doing.
You actually wanna see if
it's actually bringing value
to your lines of businesses, right?
And that's another key component
to why we built out this infrastructure.
And again, when Stephen
Short comes up here,
he'll give you a solid example.
Again, I'm gonna talk
very high level again.
That's why I said I'm 100 level right now.
But basically I do wanna mention
that literally we are seeing
agents across the stack,
specifically with
automotive and manufacturing
being deployed through almost
every single line of business.
We are gonna talk and focus
on the digital customer experience
within this particular talk,
but I am seeing software-defined vehicle
being actually agents deployed.
I am seeing in vehicle
assistance being deployed
within the head unit.
We are seeing agents actually being tested
through smart manufacturing
and call to control.
And we also are seeing product engineering
with your CAD as well
to help generate and
build out faster vehicles
and prototyping, especially
if you're a PM, right?
Sometimes us nerds, like
we nerd down too much,
but your PMs, they use
something like lovable
or some of these other stacks
so they can quickly iterate fast, right?
And basically we were
seeing productivity increase
across the board.
So I do get asked this a lot,
how do you actually do this, right?
So we're talking about
all these cool services,
how do we actually do
this for an enterprise?
And basically platform
engineering is the key, right?
Platform engineering,
if you are not familiar with that term,
I highly recommend you look it up.
It's kind of taken the world
by storm outside of agentic AI.
But basically the idea
is that you have one centralized platform,
and your platform will actually
enable DevOps at scale.
So I do, I'm actually a
platform engineering leader,
and I actually do work with
a lot of other customers
that's not just automotive
and manufacturing.
In fact, my colleague Neil
actually spoke with Cisco
on Monday about this
very particular use case.
But again, ideally one
centralized platform.
I will brag a little bit.
Toyota has like four or five.
It depends on your
organization how you're set up.
But nevertheless, you
focus on your developers,
and then you start
building out more features
and capabilities to your builders,
which I kind of use it as an et al.
And then data scientists,
and then don't forget
about your business, right?
And here you can see very quickly,
it doesn't matter where
you deploy these things.
It could be in a VPC or if you
have a corporate data center,
remember internal development platforms
to solve your cloud problems.
Now that's why.
So turns out
when you actually start using
internal development platform
throughout your organization
and you start using agentic frameworks
and integration into the IDP,
you actually have the ability
to actually deploy agents
at scale within your
own confined arguments
and scale and identity and guardrails,
so your security team's
not freaking out, right?
But basically I'm using AgentCore
icons and also MCP servers
and also I just put strands there for fun.
But ideally what you're
trying to really do
from a centralized cloud
team is democratize agents
so that anyone can deploy these
and actually scale them up at scale.
This is what I'm seeing the most for sure.
Like I just said, Cisco kind of talked
about their whole experience on Monday.
I worked with Spotify, same thing.
And this is kind of the way we're going.
So just remember it doesn't matter
if you're using Kubernetes,
Terraform, CDK, CloudFormation.
But ideally what you
would do is use something
like AgentCore
and you would let these
internal development platforms
have self-service templates,
so you can deploy them in say legal or HR
and anything like that, right?
And help scale these things up.
So story of AWS and Toyota.
This is kind of personal for me.
I've been at AWS for about
seven and a half years.
Before I actually started
really helping out Toyota,
I actually floated around
our self central enterprise
strategic and global accounts.
So I was actually
working with agriculture,
so like Tyson Foods if anyone's
ever been out to Arkansas
to have fun with that.
Also media, entertainment, gaming.
But one day I was very
lucky I got to be on Toyota.
I joined in 2018,
and their footprint was very,
very small to keep it light.
And my team alone, we have
actually spent every single day
and we're helping 'em with
their mobility journey.
And it's not just North America, right?
It's also Toyota Motor
Corporation in Japan.
It's also Toyota Connected in Japan.
Woven by Toyota.
Toyota Racing Development,
which is the NASCAR team.
They're actually using
SageMaker to predict races.
And basically I just
wanted to talk about like
if you are a customer out here,
force your account teams to do this,
because literally I
wake up in the morning,
I'm calling Toyota.
When I go to bed, I'm calling Toyota.
And that's also one big thing
too is that actually they push
on our services every single day.
And in fact we actually
are discovering new types
of workloads all the time.
And in fact,
when I walked into the
internal development platform,
I called up Kashur, which is right there,
and basically said, "Hey,
are you doing this?"
And sure enough, basically
we're on the bleeding edge
and building together.
And so basically I do only
have four use cases up here,
but there's almost about like I think 47.
It's crazy, right?
And so basically I
think a big thing for us
is that we're always learning,
we're always building,
and that's why I'm gonna
show you something better.
Stephen, if you don't
mind, let's go places.
- All right. Thank you, Bryan.
So as Bryan alluded to,
Toyota and AWS has worked
together for a very long time.
And one of the things that's
kind of led to the inception
of our journey with generative AI
was the formation of
our enterprise AI team.
The enterprise AI team
was brought together
to be a center of
excellence for generative AI
for TMNA overall, but it also
has a kind of unique factor
that we don't see in a
lot of enterprise COEs
where almost the entirety
of the team are engineers.
And so what we do is we focus
on either building AI accelerators,
which are baked into tools
that we're using in existing platforms
and then bridging the gap
between the outcome we're trying to get
and the efficiency we're trying to create.
And then at the same time
researching into ways
that we can generate new use cases
and create what we call AI teammates.
Toyota has a policy to keep our teammates
at the center of all of our work.
And so because of that,
everything is based on
augmenting our current teammates
and capabilities and going
to reach full capacity
for whatever the use case is.
And so one of the things that
Stephen Short's gonna show
is how we're looking to
enhance our capability
for delivering product
information at scale
so that our advocates in
our brand engagement center,
our end users on the websites,
our dealers in the shop
can get all of the latest
and greatest data as fast as possible,
but we don't have to create
unique custom pipelines
for every single use case and iteration
and then continue basic,
you know, the normal for
all that you see in IT.
To do that, our group has
kind of a unique structure
inside of our IT organization
where we are kind of a diagonal across.
Brian Kursar, head of global AI,
likes to call our diagonal,
we're not a horizontal.
But we start with exploration.
So this is novel use cases
starting with brand new technology
that no one's ever done before.
And then through
experimentation and education
where we work with our IT teams,
bringing that into business as usual.
So this is where if someone says,
you know, I want to use gen
AI for document retrieval
was one where they wanted
to take all of the contracts
and combine 'em together
to start looking at trends
across the entire SOW scope.
We had a couple of analysts
that were doing that.
There's 300,000 contracts.
They were getting through
about 30,000 a year.
So one of our first
implementations two years ago
was to bring that all into one platform,
use generative AI to go
through and do the analysis,
pull out all the key components,
and then turn that into analytics data
for them to look at all of it at scale.
Time reduction was somewhere
in the order of like 15
to 17 hours per user,
which then also allowed
us to start seeing things
like creep in labor increases
or like we'd see contracts
that had expiration clauses
that we were missing,
and so we're paying way more
than we should have been paying
because we weren't doing like
good decent compliance work.
And we're still evaluating
like the savings,
which continue to grow every year
as we do more and more business
with different partners.
We also take those learnings
and enable other teams to replicate.
So one of the things we're looking to do
is democratize all of
the different use cases
across the board.
So I kind of break them
down to like three groups.
You are taking data and doing analysis,
you're taking content and
generating new content,
or you're distilling disparate content
down into some unified source
that can be distributed
to different groups
and different stakeholders
depending on the audience.
Pretty much all of our use cases
fall into like that bucket.
And so once we find the capability
and are able to develop it for gen AI,
we then wanna spread it out
across the different groups
because time to market is
kind of the only key metric
that we're looking at because
this space moves so fast,
if you don't do it quickly,
you might as well not do it at all.
Once we have those identified,
then we engage with
business users for adoption.
So this is one of the things
that's probably most important
in change management is
getting people to understand
that there's no perfect version,
it's whatever version you can get done
and then you improve upon
it based on learnings.
And sometimes that is a
little bit interesting
in a manufacturing perspective
because everyone kind of
wants to de-risk the project
and plan it out perfectly before we do it.
And doing that in gen AI
just means you're behind every single day.
And then lastly, we work
with our business units
in legal and cyber and
then also for like policy
to ensure that everyone's
using all gen AI responsibly
and that we're not drifting off
or letting additional viewpoints
that are not Toyota specific
come into our products
and then turn us into a company
that may be like not exactly
following like Toyota's way.
To do that, to manage
all of that at scale,
we've kind of taken this
build, configured, buy approach
where because we started with engineers
and research scientists,
we were able to build a
lot of these capabilities
from day one.
So like as soon as ChatGPT
was available as an API,
we started building
systems from the get go.
And the reason we started building
was because those didn't
exist as products.
Once we've built them
and defined requirements
that we know work for our use cases,
we then look for a product
that can be configured
so that it can be worked
into an existing platform.
And then finally, if
those existing products
and features turn into a SaaS platform
or delivered through one
of our trusted partners,
we look to buy that based on knowing
that we're gonna get a certain
outcome from that spend,
which then allows us to then
get support to get maintenance,
get upgrades without us needing
to invest all of that money
into places that we are not the best at.
Toyota is a manufacturer for cars.
We are not a UI/UX shop.
We're not really a
software development shop,
and so it doesn't make sense for us
to try to recreate the wheel
when someone is already
delivering it at scale.
So to make that lifecycle work,
we engage with business on ideas.
So it's basically the idea
is like I want to use generative AI for X.
We engage with them from the
product management perspective
and we have a couple of
engineers that usually engage
with each unit to shape
that into a submission
for our AI/ML governance board.
And it basically means we
would look to evaluate to see
if the solution, vendor,
or the technology is gonna be compliant
with existing standards.
In some cases we find that
there is not a standard
for what we're trying to do,
and so we then help shape a new standard
to make sure that that
can be adopted by groups
across the board.
And then finally, once it goes
through the governance board,
we then engage to build prototypes,
set up productionalization plans,
and then we also help support
authorization when necessary.
There are a lot of teams that
already have their full stack,
and so once we build a prototype
or we validate the
solution, we hand it off,
and then support them by
enabling new technology.
So what that leads us to
is we are now looking at
how do we come up with a
unified enterprise strategy
for agentic SaaS.
And so what we have decided to focus on
is using this stack to
guide most of our choices
and decisions across the board
when it comes to like the future
forward looking enterprise.
So Toyota has a lot of
existing AI/ML investments.
We have an office of data science
that is gonna continue to
build models and tools.
Those tools flow up
through the business rules
and workflows that are
enabling existing processes.
And then once those processes
have been solidified
and we understand what our
KPIs are, we usually run them
through an orchestration layer that says,
okay, here's how we're going
to manage this at scale,
where there's a single team member,
it's a small team or it's an entire org.
And then utilizing
interoperability anchors,
as we were calling 'em,
MCP servers, the app protocols,
frameworks like strands agents.
We're then helping each
team build agents and bots
for their specific use case
but with a common context
that allows them to be shareable
across the organization
and also maintain
precision on the outcome.
So as models change, if we see drift,
if we need to update for new use cases
or a use case develops
like a new capability
that we hadn't seen before,
we can actually bring that back in
and update very quickly and iterate.
One of the reasons that we're
looking at it at that layer
is because we want to infuse this
into our existing platforms
so that the end users that
are actually doing this
on a day to day feel comfortable
with the space that they're
engaging with these agents
and they don't have to relearn
an entirely new UX process
to then get these capabilities.
That will really, really,
really hinder our ability
to get this out at scale,
because as most people understand,
this space changes so quickly.
Every three months there's
something different.
And so once we have an
anchor inside of a space
where a team is using it familiar,
it's a lot easier for us to
upgrade in the background
than to try to redesign those products
every single quarter at this point
because the technology moves that fast.
So for the project we're looking at today,
we were addressed with
an interesting problem.
The experience for the
dealers before gen AI kind of,
probably a little before
they came into the mix
was they were dealing with customers
who were highly researched.
Most people would go on YouTube,
they would look up a vehicle,
they would go through videos,
do a lot of information about our product,
sometimes the history of it.
I remember when the Supra
came out, you could see forms
where everyone was talking
about the differences
between the mark four and the new one
and then they go into a dealer,
and they ask the sales person,
"Hey, why should I buy this new Supra?"
And the dealer's like,
"Because I'm trying to sell it to you."
And so then they go on Google
on their phones on the side
to try to figure out why this
customer is very interested
in like the specific
model of like the engine
that's going into this vehicle
versus a different trim level.
And so to solve that,
we took all of our product
data about the vehicles
that comes from our
manufacturing, our sales,
and our marketing put that
together inside of a pipeline
that allowed it to be delivered
as a RAG implementation
in addition to governance rules
and then guidance from legal
as to how we're supposed
to manage the brand voice
and enable that to be
delivered to the dealerships
for them to like have that conversation
in concert with the user
and then also to the dot coms for them
to do product research.
And so currently that
first version of the system
is deployed to the entire dealer
body for the Toyota dealers
and we're looking at about 7,000
plus interactions per month
that is going through the system
where people were having these sales
and discovery conversations
on a regular basis.
Actually the day we submitted this deck,
Bryan sent me a video of
himself in a dealership
with the product up talking to a dealer
as like we were prepping for showing this.
So to go a little bit deeper
into how the system works,
I'm gonna hand it off
to my partner in crime,
Stephen Short.
- Hello, everyone.
Good afternoon.
My name is Stephen Short,
I'm a senior engineer at Toyota Connected.
And I'm the lead engineer on this project.
Toyota Connected is an
independent Toyota company
that works as a software development shop
and innovation hub.
Today I'm going to
provide a technical live
on what we've built out for
version one of our system,
which as Stephen said, is
a RAG based implementation
as well as where we're
heading for version two,
which is an agentic platform
that we are building within
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
To continue with the business context,
what we've built here is
we've built out an assistant,
a platform that serves as an assistant
that allows for users to
ask natural language queries
to learn about Toyota vehicle information.
You can think of this as information
such as vehicle specifications,
pricing details,
trim options, and accessory options.
And we built this in-house
as a custom RAG solution
in order to meet our business needs.
Some of the key capabilities
of our platform are one,
we integrate with Toyota
official backed data sources.
We did not want to rely on
the world knowledge of LLMs
in order to represent our vehicles.
Two, we provide accurate
citation-backed responses.
And three, we support all
Toyota North America vehicles
from model years 2023 through 2026.
In order for us to get this to production,
it was really a team effort.
We worked with many of our
business units within TMNA
such as enterprise AI, our legal teams,
and our cybersecurity teams
in order to get this out to market.
One of the key requirements
that was provided to us
from our legal teams is that any answer
that the assistant sends
needs to include contextually
relevant disclaimers.
The raw data from the sources
that we are pulling the data from,
it includes disclaimer codes as raw text,
as you can see on the left here.
The left is a segment
of a large JSON object,
which is our primary data source,
and within it it has a
disclaimer code in line
that we have to parse
and then map it to an
unaltered legal disclaimer text
that must be shown whenever
contextually relevant.
There were many other requirements
that we had to attend to as well,
such as verbiage of how
we talk about fuel economy
or Toyota Safety Sense features.
And now I'm going to walk you
through the architecture diagram
for version one of our system.
To begin, with the front end,
it will make a request to
the enterprise AI account.
It'll be routed through route 53,
which has a WAF attached to it,
and then we will utilize
Lambda edge authentication
in order to authenticate
and authorize the incoming
request utilizing Entra ID.
Once this is authorized,
then it will route to a piece of code
that is deployed within ECS
that we refer to as the intent router.
The intent router's purpose
is to identify which vehicle
that the user is asking about
so that we know which data to look up.
Before we perform any execution
or inference on the intent router,
we immediately route it to a solution
that was built in-house
by our cybersecurity team
called Prompt Guard.
Prompt Guard is a solution that
is intended to help identify
and block malicious activities
such as prompt injection.
Once this check clears,
then the intent router performs
the vehicle identification,
utilizing an external LLM.
It will create a web socket
connection with the front end.
It will initialize a conversation,
and track that history utilizing DynamoDB.
After this is done, it
will send the request over
to Toyota Connect's main account.
This will go over the internet,
go through CloudFlare,
which has a WAF attached to
it, and hit our API gateway.
From there, it will route immediately
to the Toyota Connected
Shared Services account.
This is an account that is
maintained and supported
by our cloud engineering
team at Toyota Connected,
who helped us take our solution
and help build this up and scale it up
to meet our traffic numbers.
We have our RAG application code
living within an EKS cluster
inside of this account.
We are also utilizing Datadog
for our observability platform
and we will forward all logs to this
and export those to Datadog.
When we are performing
the actual inference,
the RAG application will
call the data services
from the main account.
It'll first hit Amazon SageMaker.
It will generate embeddings
for not only the most recent query
but the previous five
turns of the conversation
and use a weighted average algorithm
in order to provide more preference
towards the most recent conversation
and then keep those within
the contextual window.
And we'll take those embeddings,
and then we will perform a semantic search
against our vector database,
which is hosted inside
of OpenSearch serverless.
We will then retrieve,
using the semantic search,
30 documents per vehicle
that is asked about.
We will use these documents as
our primary source of truth,
and then we will utilize Amazon Bedrock.
We are utilizing the
anthropic models hosted there
in order to drive the inference.
In addition to our assistant prompt
as well as the data that we retrieved,
we are then able to begin
generating an answer.
To meet our business requirements,
we also do some post-processing
on the streaming output,
which I'll dive into shortly.
Once the inference is actually completed,
we will then push them
the message to an SQS,
which is picked up from a Lambda,
which will take these logs
and pull and export them to
MongoDB, which we utilize
to satisfy our compliance
reporting requirements.
From there, we will begin
buffering the output stream
and post it back to TMNA on a web hook.
This will then add it to the
DynamoDB conversation history
and post it back to the front end client
so that it is streamed.
It is worth pointing out
that from the Toyota
Connected perspective,
the RAG application is
completely stateless.
All conversation management is handled
by the enterprise AI account.
In order to support this use case,
we had to figure out a way
to take these raw JSON data
and then translate it
into a usable format.
The approach that we took was we landed
on utilizing natural
language summarizations
for these JSON objects.
You can see an example of a single chunk
from a large JSON object
that represents one feature
of one of our vehicles.
Inside of there, there are
internal mappings for trim codes
as well as MSRP information,
descriptions, titles,
and other various fields.
We take that, and then we utilize Bedrock
to generate natural language
translations of this object
that we then utilize
in order to perform the semantic search.
In addition to the processed fields,
we also include the raw data
that the processed field
was generated from.
This raw data is important for us
to actually perform
the citations workflows
that I was mentioning previously.
And now I'm going to walk you
all through our ETL pipeline
of how we ingest this data.
We have a data account
within Toyota Connected,
which utilizes AWS Step Functions
to orchestrate a series of Glue scripts
to perform the actual extract
and transform portions of the ETL.
The first script is the extract script.
It will pull all of the
supported vehicle data
from our Toyota API servers
and then push those into S3.
The second script is the transform script.
This is the heaviest
portion of our pipeline.
In order to maximize throughput,
we were able to paralyze this,
and we are able to transform
up to around 30 vehicles concurrently.
This script will first
chunk the JSON data,
and then two, it will do the translation
that I mentioned before
and generate natural
language summarizations
using Amazon Bedrock.
Afterwards, due to the
non-deterministic nature
of LLM output, it is up to us to ensure
that these summarizations are accurate,
and hence we added data quality checks
that verify the output
of these summarizations
and ensure the accuracy of
critical pieces of information
such as pricing details
and trim availabilities.
From there, another script
will take these outputs
and generate embeddings
of the natural language summarization
and then tie together
them with the raw data
and then publish those into S3.
From there, the extract
and transform is complete.
And now we need to move on to the load.
And this is facilitated
via publishing an event
to Amazon EventBridge,
which then triggers a Lambda
on each of our dev stage
and prod accounts.
This Lambda will pull the data,
or first it will grab necessary parameters
from AWS systems manager that it utilizes
to configure an OpenSearch
ingest pipeline.
From there, it will proceed
to create a new index
in our OpenSearch collection.
This index is created
based off of the timestamp
of the start of the ETL pipeline.
Then it will proceed
to create the OpenSearch
ingest pipeline itself,
which then is configured
to read from the output
of the transform step on
our data account S3 bucket.
It will take that output
and then ingest it into
the newly created index.
Once this is completed,
we stop the pipeline,
and then the data is
almost ready to be used.
However, due to the,
as I mentioned before,
there's non-determinism
involved in every LLM call.
In order to ensure the
quality of our system
and that the newly ingested data
will meet our performance expectations,
we have created an evaluations engine
that we have created and
orchestrated a series of scripts
utilizing GitLab Runners.
Our counterparts at TMNA provided us
with a golden set of data
for one of our vehicles.
This is a series of
question and answer pairs
that has been proven from
one of the SMEs over at TMNA.
We took this output,
and we utilized it as our golden data set
in order to generate a synthetic test set.
This synthetic test set can be generated
for any of our vehicles.
We will take that output,
and then use that output
to invoke against our
deployed RAG application.
From there, we will take the
output of the evaluation calls
and actually perform utilizing
a council of LLM approach
to understand and gauge
against a series of metrics
that we've defined to measure
the performance of our system
and the quality of data.
Once this is done, then
we have an understanding
of how well the new data set is performed
and we can switch our index alias,
which is how our RAG application knows
which data set to utilize,
and point it to the newly created index.
This allows for us to
swap to a new data version
without any downtime.
Beyond evaluations, it is also
important for us to ensure
that we are meeting the
compliance guidelines
that was provided to us from our partners
from our legal teams at TMNA.
They provided us with a set of guidelines
of how the assistant
should answer questions
and how it should generally behave.
The way that we do this is
we take incoming Q&A pairs
and then we utilize Amazon Bedrock
to first categorize the incoming question
to understand what the
user was asking about,
and then two, measure how
well the response measured up
and complied with these guidelines.
We will then ingest this
compliance status to MongoDB,
which we utilize as the
primary backend database
for our compliance reporting engine.
You can see a snapshot of the front end
that we've created to support this,
and we share access to this
with our friends from legal
in order for them to understand
how the system is performing
in production.
On the topic of compliance,
one thing I mentioned before
was how we have to handle disclaimers.
In order for us to provide disclaimers
that are contextually
relevant to the output,
we have to ensure that
our disclaimers text
is treated as immutable data.
In addition to the disclaimers text,
we also support showing vehicle images,
which also the image URLs
and the image metadata also
must not be altered by the LLM.
The way that we approached
solving this problem
is we took a stream splitting approach.
We provided instructions
and provided many examples
to our system prompt
to utilize and leverage
in context learning
to split the stream into
three distinct segments.
The first is the main output stream.
This is what gets streamed
and shown directly on the front ends.
The second is a list of disclaimers codes
that the LLM will utilize as citations
and then populate the disclaimers codes
that it believes should be surfaced
as part of its inference.
And then the third, the images
follow the same principle.
Any images that need to
be shown to the end user
as part of this answer, it is published,
we collect image IDs,
and then after this is done,
we will take the list of codes
and then the list of image IDs
and then utilize a mapping
that we have available
to our service to send this
up and post it onto the stream
without ever being touched by the LLM.
An example of how we do
this is shown in the code
on the right.
We are essentially going
through the output stream
of the invoke model with
the response stream,
and we are looking for specific delimiters
for either the disclaimers
case or the images case
and then switching the state
of the output accordingly.
As we built out version one,
we saw that there were many opportunities
of how we wanted to expand our services.
First we wanted to onboard
additional data sets
and additional clients.
There's many use cases
that we could pivot into,
and we also wanted to reduce the reliance
on our ETL pipelines.
As you can see,
there's actually a lot going
on for us to do this ETL,
and this was compounded by
the fact that every year
when Toyota is rolling
out a new model year,
the frequency of changes in
this upstream data source
is very rapid, which would every
time that the data changes,
we would need to do the entire ingest
and then rerun the evaluation strategy.
This data stillness issue
was a real problem for us
and something that we
saw as an opportunity
for us to improve on.
In addition to this, the
business started to have appetite
for actions that were
beyond the capabilities
of what our version one
assistant was able to perform,
such as allowing users to ask
and look for local availability
from their local dealership
for Toyota vehicles.
As part of these opportunities,
we started to perform research
into agentic platforms.
Our early experimentations
utilizing the Strands SDK
and creating our own
agents and MCP servers
revealed to us a key finding
that we actually can utilize
due to the advancements
of both MCP and LLMs.
We are able to connect our
agents directly to the data
and then remove the support,
we were able to drop our ETL pipeline
and traditional RAG system entirely,
and then that allows us to
avoid the data stillness issues
while giving flexibility
to support actions
and advanced reasoning.
However, while this was easy
for us to put together proofs
of concepts and demo this,
actually planning a
system in agentic platform
and getting to this to
production is difficult.
Agents, they bring a lot of complexities
as well as MCP servers.
Creating sane authentication
and authorization strategies,
auto-scale and configurations
to support the expected traffic loads,
and then guaranteeing
context and session isolation
is a difficult task.
And so to reiterate,
some of the platform goals of
what we are looking to build
for version two of the system
is we are building an
extensible agentic platform.
We are going to be enabling actions,
perform enhanced auth
and session isolation
to address the complexities
of a multi-agent system
with MCP servers.
And we are going to be doing this
to support increased traffic numbers
as well as having lower
infrastructure overhead
for our team to maintain.
Our platform target for version two
is we are looking to build
a series of strands agents
and MCP servers
leveraging Amazon Bedrock
AgentCore Services.
Our early experiments in
AgentCore have been great.
The services are actually built out
to address many of the concerns
that I had of getting our
system from demo to production.
AgentCore runtime, it's a
firecracker VM-based solution
that provides isolation by default.
It's scalable as it's a
serverless technology.
And there's low infrastructure overhead
for us to build these.
AgentCore identity will tackle
the complexities of identity
and inbound and outbound authentication
within a multi-agent and multi-MCP system.
In AgentCore memory, it allows for us
to simplify the conversation
management pattern
as well as provide some
interesting novel use cases
that we can tie into our agents.
And MCP servers, there's two options here.
You can utilize AgentCore Gateway,
which is a fantastic service,
and if you need additional customization
such as response caching,
what I found is that we can
actually deploy the MCP servers
into AgentCore runtime and
couple them with memory,
which I'll dive into shortly.
And now I'm going to walk you
through our target infrastructure diagram
for version two of our system.
As you can see on the left,
much of the stack from the
enterprise AI side is similar.
There are two key pieces that
I want to point out however.
First is that we are looking
to replace the intent router
with an orchestrator.
This orchestrator will
integrate with an agent registry
that Toyota Connected will be building.
This agent registry,
you can think of it as a
mapping of authenticated clients
to which agents are available
to each calling client.
Utilizing this registry,
when a front end request comes
in and hits the orchestrator,
the orchestrator will know
what agents are available
for the client,
and then it will route it
to the appropriate agent.
We are also looking to
remove the external LLM calls
that we utilize inside of the
intent router in version one
and utilize Bedrock calls
for that orchestrator in V2.
On the right in the Toyota
Connected infrastructure,
you can see I have a couple of agents,
the product expert agent and
the product support agent.
Both of these are going
to be strands agents
that are deployed within
AgentCore runtime.
These agents are going to
be coupled with MCP servers
that provide tools that
are necessary for them
in order to do their job.
So we have a couple of
options for MCP servers
as I mentioned.
We believe that AgentCore gateway
is going to be a perfect fit
for our product support MCP server.
To back up a little bit,
to explain the differences
between the agents,
the product expert agent,
you can think of it
as basically agentifying
the version one capabilities
of our platform.
That's the purpose of that agent.
And the product support
agent is a separate agent
that is intended to help
service customer inquiries
about their vehicle.
So we believe the product
support MCP server
will be a good fit for AgentCore Gateway.
The product expert MCP server, however,
it is on us to ensure that
we are responsible consumers
of the Toyota APIs that drive
the data for this agent.
As such, we must implement
response caching.
It's a hard requirement.
We have to make sure that we do it.
And I found via some
experiments last week actually
that we can utilize AgentCore memory
in order to achieve response caching.
And I'm going to provide an example
of how we can utilize memory
as a distributed cache,
and it looks like it will
work quite well actually.
In addition to these AgentCore services,
we are looking at utilizing
the other AgentCore services
such as AgentCore observability.
It supports open telemetry by default,
so we will be passing these along
and forwarding the logs
to our Datadog instance.
We'll be utilizing AgentCore
identity to integrate
with our chosen identity provider.
And we will continue
to support our compliance
analysis workflows.
In order for us to
perform response caching,
one of our experiments
that we've been doing is,
I'll walk you through it.
So we have our product expert agent,
which will be making a tool call
to the corresponding MCP server.
From there, we'll first check to ensure
whether or not this exists in the cache.
We are utilizing AgentCore
memory event metadata
to accomplish this.
So if there is a cache hit,
it'll pull the information
from the event metadata
and then pass it up to the calling agent.
On a cache miss, we will be going out
and making the call to the external APIs
and then caching them
within the response cache.
On the right, you can see
some code that I've created
that is a decorator of which
we can apply to any tool call
within our MCP server.
This is a decorator
that essentially takes
the function signature
as well as the parameters that
are passed in the invocation,
concatenates them together,
and then creates a hashing
key utilizing SHA-256.
Once we have this caching key,
we can then make a look up
within AgentCore memory.
So I wanted to touch in on this
because this is an important
piece of information.
Utilizing the AgentCore Bedrock
SDK for AgentCore memory,
it exposes a high level client.
This high level client has a
list of events function on it.
However, while a high level client
does not have the capability
to filter based off of event metadata.
However the low level client does.
And you can access the
low level client directly
utilizing the code that
I have on the bottom.
This code will invoke the GMDP
client list events function,
which is identical with
additional functionality
to support this metadata filtering option.
On the top, you can see how
we utilize the metadata filter
and construct that query on event metadata
only if the cache key matches.
This allows for us to achieve our goal
of utilizing AgentCore
memory as a response cache.
It's also worth pointing out,
in order for AgentCore memory to be shared
across different sessions
of the actual MCP server,
it is important to note that
you have to configure a couple
of key pieces of information.
I believe it's the actor
ID and it's the session ID
or the agent ID.
I can provide that afterwards.
Anyways, once you have that,
you statically code
those lookup variables,
then memory can actually
act as a shared cache
across any agents.
And to walk away with
some of the key findings
that we've had from version
two of our product APIs
is AgentCore services are great.
They're going to enable us
to build an agentic platform
that doesn't bring aboard all
of the infrastructure
overhead complexities
that we were anticipating
pivoting into an agentic future.
And also AgentCore,
utilizing the combination of agents MCP
will allow us to avoid
the data stillness issues
that we have today in version one.
And that we are targeting
our launch in Q1 of 2026.
And thank you everybody for attending.